Albuquerque has been a punching bag for
a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town the latest a well-known
comedian who bashed the city after
playing at a city-owned treasure the
Kimo News 13s Rebecca Adkins is live
there with what he said and how people
are responding Rebecca well came
according to ticket sales this is where
chris d'elia performed last thursday but
while he was here he had some sort of a
bad experience after chris d'elia is a
big name in the comedy world and
thursday night he performed at the Kimo
theater it was his second time in
Albuquerque but something on this visit
left a bad taste in his mouth
after his performance downtown he took
to Twitter to take a jab at Albuquerque
saying I've been to some blank holes but
holy God you make Jacksonville look like
paradise
the post has been retweeted almost 600
times I just thought that was pretty
rude of him it was kind of unnecessary
to bash a place that you're attending
people we spoke to weren't too happy
about what he said and on Twitter people
had mixed feelings
this person listed off Albuquerque
staples like green chile and the
Sandia's and said what more could you
want others agreed with D'Elia with one
person saying they're from here and
should be offended but then said you're
right
hashtag past the meth do not the man on
fire shortly after that tweet he posted
again saying Albuquerque and
Jacksonville crowds are awesome though
actually but some people feel posts like
that could scare tourists away
oh you should probably apologize for
that
we also reached out to Albuquerque's
tourism department they say the post is
unfortunate but they'd like to know if
something's set D'Elia off while he was
here they do say however they're
appreciative of all the locals that
stood up for the city came back to you
okay thanks for Becca now we also
reached to out to Daliya through his
Twitter we have not yet heard back he
did have some nice things to say about
Santa Fe in Twitter after performing at
the lens ik actually I had a great time
in Albuquerque doing my show but once I
left the show where am i well came
according to ticket sales this is where
Chris D'Elia performed at last Thursday
but according to ticket sales what just
Google in the act like they did so many
[ __ ] someone's research
well according to stickit sales what do
you mean cuz [ __ ] 1500 people bought
tickets to see me that's not according
to ticket sales
just look so this is what I saw then I
said on on Twitter I was making fun
Albuquerque because if you live in
Albuquerque you've got to know where the
[ __ ] you live don't pretend this [ __ ]
isn't narnia the buildings go this high
you got to crouch down to get into any
place ash the city after playing at a
city-owned treasure the Kimo
News 13s Rebekah actually sure what he
said and how people are responding
Rebekah
Bekka always with the wait too long
cause hey news newscasters do it when
their jump on the last sentence if
you're in the field jump on that last
sentence jump on it we're going live
took it this is me we're good this is me
if I'm a newscaster we're going live to
Chris D'Elia in the field to see what
some of the locals have to say about hey
guys how's it going I'm cutting them off
I'm feeling it out dude
rather than that's way better than we're
going live to the field Chris D'Elia to
see how locals feel about what he said
on Twitter
hi how's it going I just want to do this
too long man
I could eat lunch in the middle of that
pause that pause is so [ __ ] long a
baby came out of it so so still Lia
performed at last Thursday but while he
was here he had some sort of a bad
experience no your oh you're bad news I
didn't say I had a bad experience I just
said Albuquerque just calling me an
actor you know what I mean by letting me
know you know what dude you say other
people's lines dude second time in
Albuquerque but something on this visit
left a bad taste in his mouth who writes
this [ __ ] you know it's amazing but
something about this visit left a bad
taste in his mouth by the way they've
shown the theater in this video fourteen
times so far get more footage so much of
this yet from the top dude this is such
a news to get the top of the viewer and
the Quran at the Kimo theater but
something left a bad taste in this
comedians mouth he tweeted on Twitter
that Albuquerque wasn't good we've
talked to some of the locals to see what
they have to say always [ __ ] panning
down dude just show it you don't have
more footage just cuz you're moving the
camera we can tell dude guess what every
time they do this too they [ __ ] come
down and there's a parts plus auto parts
[ __ ] car drive by same footage also
parts plus auto parts if parts is in
your [ __ ] title twice change it parts
plus auto parts come on down two parts
plus auto parts where will parts if your
parts and parts that'll be parts fifty
please parts plus auto parts dude too
many peas parts plus auto parts plus
parts partum depression parts pardon put
plots pissing to piss parts parts dude
get it together Albuquerque you have a
[ __ ] auto place called parts plus
auto parts and also a theater and named
after cancer I mean how creepy it's not
that bad you just gotta go to like
Albuquerque's not bad that bad use gotta
go to good parts of it you know what the
good parts of Albuquerque are Los
Angeles others agreed with D'Elia with
one person saying they're from here and
should be offended but then said you're
right
hashtag past the map hashtag past the
meth and on fire shortly after that
tweet he posted again saying Albuquerque
and Jacksonville crowds are awesome
though actually but some people feel
posts like that could scare tourists
away probably not gonna want to come
here now you should probably apologize
for that
we also reached out to Albuquerque's
tourism department they say the post is
unfortunate but they'd like to know if
something's set daliyah off while he was
here they do say however they're
appreciative of all the locals that
stood up for the city came back to you
okay thanks for Becca now we also
reached to out to Daliya through his
Twitter we have not yet heard back
he didn't some nice things to say about
Santa Fe in Twitter after performing at
the Lindsey I mean just so many just
keep going and [ __ ] we wonder what he
thinks about Seattle just like okay you
know also lets it a cliffhanger how they
left it although he did have some nice
things to say about Santa Fe by the way
what she's saying that at the end in the
background the next news is I swear to
God the next segment it says child shot
[Music]
how did I beat out that story one of
Albuquerque's own slain but I tweeted it
was a blank hole maybe Albuquerque
that's the problem start from there
rename your theater and then move on
[Music]
the over social media shedding more
light on his comets Chris D'Elia
performed earlier this month at the Kimo
theater afterwards he took to Twitter
saying quote I've been to some blank
holes but holy blink you make
Jacksonville look like paradise many New
Mexicans criticized him on social media
well a couple days after our story aired
Tilly responded to the outcry saying he
couldn't believe the response I was
there for eight hours twice I'm sure
it's fine how could you get upset about
somebody saying something like that now
he still hasn't revealed an exact reason
for not liking Albuquerque but he did
poke fun at Kimo theatres name and said
our buildings are short guess what you
know you know I never thought I'd go to
war with a city I never thought I'd go
to war with the city but I'm at war with
a city baby I talked about Albuquerque
on [ __ ] Twitter and they [ __ ] and
then I and guess what now they endued
they're back another segment two
segments two segments too many I'm a
correspondent at this point dude they
came back and did another segment last
episode I talked about Albuquerque and
they did a segment on me about how I
quote unquote bash them and this [ __ ]
unbelievable dude prop Albuquerque's
turned out to be my favorite [ __ ]
city in the u.s. dude just because of
their [ __ ] they clap back they have a
clap back effect I was there for eight
full and my podcast on their [ __ ]
news segment Weiss I'm sure it's fine
something like that
now he still hasn't revealed an exact
reason for not liking Albuquerque but he
did poke fun at Kimo theatres name does
the best part and said our buildings are
short
you bet he did poke fun at Kimo theaters
name and said our buildings are short
did the newscaster said that
[Music]